today I am going on a first date snack
swap
I don't like tender like hinge like
dating app dates but never like a
full-on blind date so this is terrifying
I have been on a blind date 13 years ago
we remained friends I don't think we
like had like a small fling or whatever
by it I know love blossom I'm nervous
about the other people snacks because
spicy is way in right now and I can do a
little bit of spicy but like I don't
want anything that's gonna like burn out
my mouth I don't think my opinion would
change on someone's choices snack but
then again I've never went on a date
with anybody who had these crazy snack
choices so maybe and I'm also gonna
judge people if they don't like my
snacks because my snacks are pretty
basic and pretty classic and that's what
I'm looking for in life I don't want to
move like fancy snacks my favorite go-to
snacks are Oreos Lay's potato chips I
love swedish fish too I'm a very picky
eater so there are certain snacks that
I'm not gonna try I don't eat meat to
some sort of animal by-products that
came at the cost of some animal
suffering I'm gonna have to take a hard
pass I have no expectations I guess
hoping to get some good snacks hopefully
somebody else has love for Oreos like me
I don't expect to fall in love over
snacks today but I could be pleasantly
surprised BuzzFeed let me know okay so
I'm ready to meet my date there's snacks
involved how can I go wrong right
[Music]
[Music]
full disclosure to the audience
Trey and I have been snacking all week
do you know it was gonna be a blind
snack date today though I'm very excited
though because I I think that you'll
appreciate my snacks I'm a little
nervous because I know that you and I
have very different like eating styles
ie you like me I do but I have faith in
you Becky I didn't pick any vegan snacks
okay I appreciate so well I didn't know
with you I might um if I knew it was you
one told me that
Oreos vegan I don't know if that's true
they are that is true Oreos are vegan
but there's a controversy because they
use palm oil internet you decide first
category is chips Troy I'm gonna let you
go first you can't go wrong with the
classic lace I mean it's it's so
American I love it I was ever was here
was gonna pick like takis and I was like
I don't know ya know I too want a very
classic routes the original Cheetos good
I think they're losing to spicy cheater
like hot cheetos hot cheetos are fine
they have a place I'm not a huge fan of
classics just classic American snacks
that's it should we do it why should
Cheers
yeah I was gonna say we could do it like
yeah these are just good they're like a
good foundation of a girl
that's all you really need you can only
find hot cheetos everywhere and they're
fine big bigger whatever but like a
classic regular cheeto huh I feel like
people are gonna hate me for not liking
hot cheetos but I love them neither I'm
stoked you know you can't go wrong with
just don't get me nothing fancy just
some good old cheese and puffs
whatever the heck first swap was
definitely a success next up the dessert
what do you got we're yet own Oreos
classic wonderful snack I love them
traditional love them too much you know
blood sugar is not where it should be my
snack is
the classic it is my favorite of all
time oh I love these nice crispy treats
you don't need a lot you just need a
little butter no marshmallow and crunch
so I was terrified that whoever got
paired up with me which is gonna be like
I only beef jerky and I was gonna be
like I can't eat that my stomach will
hurt for a week yeah I wouldn't do that
I am so stoked that my blind date was so
considered about the environment and the
environmental impact that vegan and
vegetarian items don't have and to
provide a classic snack for me it rice
krispies treats it just takes you back
to being a kid you know like I remember
like people would bring in treats for
like a classroom party or whatever and
somebody's mom always made rice krispies
treats and I always was excited about it
it's so simple but it's the same thing
with Oreos they're just like a classic
good snacks you don't need to be fancy
the reason these snacks have been around
since forever is cuz they're good
swap number two uh flying smashing
success
the last swap is candy and if you like
it so Mario's in my teeth
yes I hope you enjoy again you know me
I'm a simple girl I like simple things
yes I okay I haven't had a KitKat in a
long time those are under it's because
they're hard to find them first and now
I feel like they're all these C's like
white chocolate ones no you just want a
classic you know with that sweet crunch
all right here we go
I'm nervous those are also vegan they're
an underrated snack oh they're so good
yes I could just eat the whole box right
yeah if you love me that's why I yeah
someone had to kick that it was one of
those things that I really really really
liked and you eat it correctly you break
it apart yeah genius KitKat company if
you want to endorse me I'll take it I
love it it's so good yeah again I don't
want white chocolate cake Packers dark
chocolate want to pick that it's
sacred Swedish Fish they come in other
flavors which are also good but not as
good at the read I got my another boy
yeah yeah yeah you have time it's hard
if I ever find a bag this is great this
is the best snack swap ever this is so
much better than my expectation it was
also the best first date I've been on in
a really long yeah I'm happy yeah now
you know other than this hats that I'm
okay with Becky's you know okay good
sense look at that but the shirt saver
Troy yes how do you think the date way I
think it went really well I'm looking
forward to more snap dates with you I am
baking this weekend Oh can't wait for
Monday then so that we can enjoy another
snack for lunch I think it went great a
good company even better snacks nothing
to complain about
[Music]